world
voilà alors voilà donc cesser votre
compagnie alexandre
c'est vrai que ça c'est ça a été une
image on s'est tous dit c'est
inadmissible de voir ça qu'ils nous ont
pensé vous il n'est pas attaqué ouais
l'image même les faits les gestes on
peut pas ne pas pardonner
sachez que moi même je suis pas je suis
pas d'accord par rapport à tout ça
surtout que les pompiers on en a eu
souvent besoin dans nos mobilisations
depuis pratiquement quatre ans
maintenant ça a été nos sauveurs dans
les minutes
parce que des fois on a eu des mains
arrachées on a eu des yeux donc ça a été
quand même bannu est ce que nos héros du
moment je dirais même que c'est vrai que
nous on nous a souvent défendu ici dans
cette émission et voilà on comprend la
colère de certains français et des
combes les pompiers aussi comprennent
voilà la colère de certains français qui
n'en peuvent plus et qui se retrouvent
dans des situations inextricables et qui
se retrouve on le dit souvent cette
expression de 10 du mois sans rien et
qui se disent ya une injustice
incroyable et on allait gilet jaune
notamment et tout mouvement des filets
jaunes mais c'est vrai que là l
agression de deux de ses pompiers
pourquoi pourquoi elle a fait ça en fait
c'était qu'est-ce que vous avez n'est
mieux une personne qui a été vers les
pompiers au départ mais normalement
c'est une personne aussi dans toutes les
manifestations quand les manifestants se
prennent un peu la tête avec les forces
de l'ordre est souvent là pour
temporiser les choses d'un côté comme de
l'autre d'ailleurs et la ligue a été au
départ et on n'a pas compris d'ailleurs
le raisonnement parce que c'est pas la
personne qui réagit comme ça normalement
manifestations et a en plus qu'à
l'habitude de travailler d'ailleurs avec
les pompiers parce que elle et medic
moi même je comprends pas et le même
acheteur si je pense que elle doit pas
doit pas comprendre ce qu'elle a fait
non plus mais manquent pas mais non mais
c'est sûrement et eric bouillard dit
vouloir parole des pompiers
les pompiers six essais no hero c'est
vraiment me dit c'est vraiment site on
dort on doit les respecter à fond et
sacré voici sacré mais c'est vrai que
moi quand je vois des images comme ça ça
fait ça me fait extrêmement peu ce que
je trouve qu'il ya plus de respect
souvent des pompiers alors qu'ils sont
là pour nous aider et qu'on en a
extrêmement besoin il faut les protéger
le plus possible et ça quand on voit ça
c c c c pas possible américain je crois
que effectivement les images parlent
d'elles-mêmes c'est des actes qu'on ne
peut plus tolérer j'étais venu déjà ici
en parler j'avais parlé de vol de
matériel là il y en a de plus en plus
voilà se parler aussi d'actes violents à
l'encontre des pompiers lors d'une
manifestation aussi là encore un
collègue de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris mais aussi
partout en france et encore des actes
qui sont à l'encontre de fait qui
protège les secours au quotidien as
raison d'une une intervention toutes les
7 secondes là ce qui est effroyable
c'est que clairement c'est un acte voilà
c'est volontaire c'est une image choc
que que peut-être la personne regrette
c'est effectivement je suis voilà je
pourrais tout ça tant de ses excuses de
sa part bien sûr mais néanmoins
aujourd'hui ce que l'on constate c'est
que ces images circulent et ça montre
clairement que naudin nos services
publics sont vulnérables et
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas cela que l'on
veut aujourd'hui la république c'est
nous c'est pas lui lui ou l'autre c'est
nous ce sont l'ensemble des services
publics que ce soit les forces de
secours les forces de sécurité
l'ensemble de tous les services
administratifs qui au quotidien
subissent malencontreusement on va dire
tout simplement cessé acte complètement
volontaire de ces personnes qui agresse
en permanence et aujourd'hui on ne
souhaite plus de ça parce que pourquoi
parce que peut-être qu'on est gratuit
j'en sais rien parce qu'on porte secours
parce qu'on est tous vulnérables
aujourd'hui on ne doit plus laisser
passer ce genre de choses là ces actes
là sont des oeuvres puni condamnable le
présent la fédération nationale des
pompiers de france s'est exprimé le
préfecture de police de paris aussi plus
possible de skoda ce ça ne peut plus
être tolérable aujourd'hui on essaie de
lutter pour recruter l'engagement des
sapeurs pompiers volontaires au
quotidien on a besoin c'est 80 % de nos
effectifs aujourd'hui qui partagent leur
temps professionnel familial avec un
temps de casernes c'est pas dans ce but
là nous ce que l'on souhaite c'est que
lisez cette envie de s'engager pas pour
subir cela donc clairement aujourd'hui
aussi une chose qui est effroyable c'est
qu'on regarde tout le monde cette
action-là ecotour que des téléphones
portables une personne vient soustraire
la star team ray et cette culture là la
sécurité civile de dire je vais venir
porter secours à celui qui nous porte
secours c'est même pas venu à l'esprit
tiens à les faire filmer et donc ça
c'est pas tolérable non plus et ça
prouve que quelque part on a réussi ce
manque de culture et de la proche de
protection civile en nous au sein de
l'état français est clairement
aujourd'hui c'est une notion qui doit
être interministériel ise c'est à dire
qu'en gros on doit avoir aussi bien au
niveau de l'écologie au niveau aussi
bien au niveau de développement durable
que le reste une notion aussi de
sécurité de protection civile parce
qu'ils envoient de la sécurité de tous
on voit les flammes et les fumées
s'échappent et nationaux rappelle quand
même que sont les fumées qui tue sont
pas les flammes exactement et que les
fumées qui s'échappent du sinistre
peuvent rentrer dans les appartements
des vieilles personnes et la pauvre
petite mamie qui est là qui n'a rien
demandé mais elle va se retrouver alité
et nous peut-être de trois heures plus
tard on va partir pour une personne ne
répondant aux appels et la famille va
constater le décès avec nous et on aura
et puis faire parce que justement il y
aura eu un sinistre au mieux de la voie
publique donc tout ça fait qu'à un
moment donné ce top sites à plessé nous
laissons les sapeurs-pompiers tranquille
laissant aussi les forces de l'ordre
travailler dans dans l'ordre qu'il de ce
doigt parce que on parle de cette image
choc mais derrière et vous aviez des
familles vous aviez des gens qui faisait
la manifestation de manière qu'ils
étaient confiants de voir les forces de
sécurité où ça exactement et qu'à partir
de là on n'a pas le droit d'en cacher
cette question de fête et cette question
de cohésion avec cette image là on va
voir cette image il ya une question de
mon ami jérôme rodriguez qui est
intéressante j'aimerais collet que c'est
nous et répondiez alex on regarde
cette image qui a énormément tourné avec
yahia jérôme audry gazole qui est un
pote hakim écrit juste une petite
question pourquoi la compagne
d'alexandre porter un casque pour une
manifestation pour moi laissez là bas
pour la violence inouïe l'intérêt dans
la case de produits mois d'errance n est
pas ici pas jérôme d'ailleurs saint des
saints doute c'est un autre pote je suis
trompé de mur rouge lembras aussi oui
bah de toute façon tous nommés dit que
la plupart ont des casses même la
plupart des médias ont des casques aussi
parce que des fois ça arrive qui paye
art des projectiles quand il ya des
charges policières il ya des coups de
matraque aussi qu' on a eu beaucoup de
crâne fendu encore même ce week-end de
toute façon et c'est vrai que nos
médicaments les protéger au maximum et
la plupart sont tous casque et qu'est ce
que vous auriez à dire alexandre du soir
à eric brocardi porte parole des
pompiers au nom de votre compagne qui a
eu un comportement inadmissible déjà je
voudrais m'en excuser par rapport à tous
les pompiers de france d'ailleurs parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup on
entend beaucoup souvent des violences à
droite à gauche par rapport à eux et qui
sont nos premiers sauveur nos héros même
même souvent quand ils passent dans les
manifestations et ce moment applaudi on
leur ouvre le chemin enfin on fait tout
en même temps pour eux parce que ba isse
nos sauveurs ils nous ont aidés
mouzon
lauzon vachement aider donc
le geste ou aider les web après moi je
m'en excuse je pense que si à peu un
jour venir sur le plateau j'espère
qu'elle pourra pour s'en excuser là
aussi elle vraiment moi ce que je sais
qu'elle fera je connais son fond je sais
comme marley et
y'a pas grand chose à dire par rapport à
ça c'est en revenant par l'insee c'est
horrible pendant la pause avec alexandre
et c'est vrai que voilà nous on est les
premiers à vraiment à défendre toutes
les personnes voilà qui sont dans la rue
pacifiquement pour faire avancer les
choses et pour que puisse voilà je vous
le dis moi on le redit à chaque fois
mais les gilet jaune ils ont quand même
faire avancer pas mal de choses ici on
était sur les sur les ronds-points
pendant des semaines et des semaines et
c'est vrai que ça fait quand même
nom mais je sais un exemple non mais ça
voilà ça ça ça fait ferrer classé c'est
vraiment je vous dis j'achèterai très
mauvais et au contraire un tous vos
détracteurs se servent de ça derrière
faire tomber dessus voilà et c'est bien
sur cet assassinat mais aussi parce
qu'elle a fait c'est très mauvais que ça
soit envers eux comme envers le
mouvement le mouvement des gilets jaunes
ça nous discriminent is complètement
aussi même envers les medics plein de
choses mais mon élection je veux dire
vraiment il ya beaucoup de réactions qui
dit bravo
c'est quand même là son courage d'être
venus si son aval à ce serment vous eric
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que effectivement eu le courage de venir
parce que cette note a bien sûr merci
avec son jardin dans le couloir et
endosser ce rôle là et devenir à
l'expliquer et prendre la parole pour
cette personne là c'est pas toujours ce
pas toujours évident et la couarde le
faire mais néanmois ce qui est ce qu'il
faut expliquer surtout c'est que ce type
d'image aujourd'hui doit plus servir on
va dire malencontreusement d'exemples de
ce qu'il ne faut pas faire ouais tout
avait par contre dans un certain sens
monter plutôt des vrais réaction
derrière positif qui aurait pu à un
moment donné faire comprendre à tout un
chacun que chacun aujourd'hui a son rôle
à jouer dans la sécurité dans la
protection de tous chers donc dans ce
cadre là on le voit au niveau des
sapeurs pompiers on parle du street
medic je tiens juste à rappeler une
chose c'est que quand il ya une
manifestation quelles qu'elles soient
sportives festives tout ce qu'on veut il
ya forcément un ordre qui est arrangé
par la préfecture quand je dis à
rallonge et c'est aussi ordonnancée par
la préfecture c'est à dire qu'en gros
les services de secours les services de
sécurité toutes les autres forces qui
contribue comme le samu ou autres à
faire en sorte que tout soit bien
sécurisée pendant cette manifestation là
ont des directives ont des ordres
opérationnels pour pouvoir se
positionner à tel ou tel endroit en
fonction des scénarii qui sont qui sont
qui sont aujourd'hui pré positionner par
rapport à l'évolution de manifestations
dans les street indique ce ne sont pas
les vidéos sur la table de la préfecture
je ne roule pas en cause leur volonté de
vouloir aider on met simplement qu est
ce qu un moment donné ça peut perturber
les forces de secours les forces de
sécurité dans le choix entre prendre et
surtout à un moment donné c'est à dire
mais si c'est un vrai c'est pas vrai en
fait il y en a pas pour nous ça n'existe
pas ils veulent porter secours très bien
qu'ils rentrent dans une association
agrée de sécurité civile comme la croix
rouge comme toute autre protection
civile et à partir de là il endosse un
rôle et puis après ils apprendront des
fonctions mais aujourd'hui c'est le
scénario manque là trop flou je pense
après le problème c'est qu'ils nous ont
vachement servir aussi à ce que vous
n'êtes pas à l'instar de la
manifestation vous arrivé qu'après une
fois que les choses sont faites mais il
n'ose y ont leurs biens si on était a
baissé sur ordre et six sur la
protection aussi des primes aux
intervenants - donc à partir de là on
nous en demande d'intervenir en fonction
de ce qu'on nous remontent comme
information et on intervient une fois
qu' il n'y a pas de risque particulier
il y en a eu des incidents
malencontreusement des gens comme marché
qu'on trébuche et tout s'est passé dans
le calme on a cédé 6 des zones 30
parents tous et des choses qui passent
sous les écrans radars comme les 4,3
millions d'interventions par an des
pompiers qui font qu'au quotidien ça
fonctionne là ça ne fonctionne plus avec
ça merci en tout cas alexandre d'être
venu en face d'eux eric brocarde ips est
important et juste des seals et moi
juste dire c'est que
d'accord cette image elle est horrible
c'est au révisable il en reconnaît par
contre ont toujours les manifestants
agressé par contre comme un week end du
1er mai où c'est que je peux vous dire
il ya eu énormément de blessés aussi
côté manifestants on n'entend jamais
parler et policiers et ça c'est vraiment
très huit blessés et huit blessés ou
dans les forces de l'ordre dans les
foyers mais il faut préciser ouais ouais
pas deux poids deux mesures faut qu'on
parle de tout on a quand même des jeunes
qui sont mineurs avec des crânes fendu
on a quand même des demoiselles avec des
crampes fondu à plusieurs endroits donc
c'est quand même différent on n'en parle
jamais des gens piétiner qui se sont
faits les ponts question de se rebeller
les forces de l'ordre sur le protecteur
aussi il faut quand même le rappeler
aussi c'est un métier qui ce qui se
respecte said that is des fois aussi de
temps en temps parce que regarder le
canton prend la province les
manifestations ne sont pas encadrées
elles ne sont pas sur les côtés on n'est
pas menacée il n'y a pratiquement pas de
violence
à paris on est encadré d'un bout à
l'autre on à la menace on comprend
pourquoi regarder ça et à la rue il ya
eu des vitrines de détruit des commerces
détruits des gens qui on
va toujours parler des dégradations up
toujours parler de tout ça mais les gens
à partir de ça fait quelques étincelles
fait mais met énormément donné je pense
qu'il commence à avoir une colère chacun
s'exprime à sa façon il ya des gens qui
s'expriment en chantant il y en a qui
s'exprime en carbone chante je tombe
c'est peut-être mieux que vegas et après
chacun est libre de son choix bah alors
en fait parce que quand on casse on ben
oui oui voyez mais libre de son choix
parce qu'on détruit l'outil de travail
de plein de gens ici n'ont rien demandé
les grands patrons du cac 40 que vous
pénaliser ses les premiers de cordée
c'est les agents de sécurité c'est les
agents d'entretien c'est des gens
modestes qui ont besoin de bosser et là
ils peuvent pas voter parce que ça a été
qu'un tueur je peux pas parler au nom de
après ces biens existants me manque
aussi casser du pompier s'cusez moi
sinon c'est la vie des autres à ça je
suis pas d'accord non mais ça je ne
tiens pas d'accord donc ce geste là je
ne suis pas d'accord
on n'est pas d'accord moi même tout à
l'heure la république c'est nous c'est
l'ensemble des services publics auxquels
tout le monde adhère aujourd'hui tout le
monde doit se rassembler parce qu'on est
encore un dernier rempart physique ouais
on est encore dernier rempart où il n'ya
pas de plexiglas pas de a fait téléphone
portable pour communiquer et donc à
partir de là il ne faut surtout pas
rentrer dans cette zone de danger non
mais moi je soutiens entièrement les
pompiers et le g je ne suis pas d'accord